[MUSIC PLAYING]
Micro air vehicles present
a very appealing platform
for search and rescue, civil
engineering inspection,
and a myriad of
other tasks where
it would be difficult or
dangerous to send a human.
By flying over
difficult terrain,
MAVs skip many of the
most challenging aspects
of using a ground vehicle
to carry out these missions.
In environments where
GPS is available,
many researchers have
developed systems
capable of high-level
autonomous behaviors.
The Robust Robotics Group
and the Computer Science
and Artificial Intelligence
Laboratory at MIT
has developed a micro
air vehicle capable
of high-level
autonomous behaviors
in unconstrained
GPS-denied environments.
We have outfitted a quad
rotor helicopter developed
in collaboration with
Ascending Technologies
with a suite of
sensors and algorithms
that successfully
closed the loop
and stabilize the vehicle
in unknown environments.
Using a lightweight
laser scanner,
we're able to perform
high-resolution scan matching
in real time to estimate the
vehicle's relative position.
These state estimates
are accurate enough
that we can accurately
identify and locate
a window in a 3D point cloud
generated from the raw laser
scans.
This narrow window not
much wider than a vehicle
highlights the accuracy
and performance
of our state estimation
and control algorithms.
The laser and
stereo camera allows
us to perform obstacle
avoidance in 3D.
The real-time state sensing
and state estimation algorithms
provide us with a very
stable and robust platform
on which to build a suite of
high-level mapping and planning
capabilities that do not
need to take into account
the fast and unstable
micro air vehicle dynamics.
We have integrated
the quad rotor
with a SLAM solution that allows
us to map unknown environments.
The map generated by
the SLAM algorithm
also allows us to perform
completely autonomous
exploration of
unknown environments.
The exploration module
seeks to balance
learning the geometrical
extent of the environment
with sweeping known boundaries
of the map for a visual target.
This process must also
choose trajectories
that ensure the vehicle
remains well localized.
This research culminated
in our team's entry
into the 2009 AUVSI
International Aerial Robotics
Competition.
The mission was executed
completely autonomously.
The vehicle had to
take off, detect,
and fly through a window,
explore an unknown environment
to find a designated control
panel using the onboard color
camera.
Our vehicle completed the
fifth mission in the first year
it was held--
a feat that had not been
achieved in the 19-year history
of the IARC competitions.